one last of the real rejects I'm Greg
Alva I'm John Humphrey welcome back to
the real rejects new rock stars one of
our favorite channels here Batman
full batsu revealed Catwoman and
batcycle scene I was out of town this
weekend I did see a little bit on social
media about this coming out didn't have
time to talk about it unfortunately John
could have done a video didn't shame
shame shame shame shame shame anywho if
you guys haven't subscribed a new rock
stars yet and you got to make sure to do
that as soon as you can let's check this
out I'm Erik Bosse and the Batman was
Robert Pattinson in the cow gave us our
first official look at the character
test footage and now some photos and
video have revealed Bruce Lee in action
or double actually a number of
interesting visual clues in this costume
design actually already start breaking
down the guy's face or is that like new
things we pack in what this footage
could tell us about this movie the story
honestly it's probably a little sooner
rush to judgment over whether the cow
Lanier's max what was in here what's
your new rock stars landing ferry moving
even though I do not have any inside
information about this movies plaques
this is really the speculation using the
same covered three years without
appeared at the bottom yeah looks like a
new bad cycle with spiky bad ears on the
handlebars that will definitely took out
some dive as Iran is bad ears on the
handle stem lifestyle Catwoman this Lego
Batman shows this the ears of Batman's
cowl which looks sharp as hell like a
bit thorny as if his head was covered in
tar and just like pinched and scrunched
up in a two point look at that I get
stupid don't worry just to kind of
rotate it to the side and hey looks a
lot more classic as we speculated from
the chest footage the eyepieces
are indeed cupboard make me think at
least this cowl could be a kind of biker
helmet
he solders in what most interesting to
me are his dauntless
they are lined with these going to
quills fire off or you know maybe just
pins for a Batman to try to replicate
the Joker's magic trick somewhat pointed
out that these gauntlets resemble the
ones worn by Talon Talon is a DC
character of a villain turned Batman a
lie former assassin for Gotham's core
tools a shadowy cult that secretly
controls the city similar to how the
League of Shadows interested in Chris
Nolan's Batman Begins what interesting
the studiously a holster and some
pouches maybe for a Batman its grappling
gun Bell looks even more detachable and
weapon here yeah and that lighting it
really does look I got a gun the gun
that killed his parents even more
clearly here you can see the edges of
the wings look sharpened as if edges of
knives I mean I think about episode a
good question to see us reverse
engineering this Mythbusters style to
determine whether it's more like a
Batarang or two knives back-to-back will
you sign it we figured it out and you'll
notice how it loves the movies not
acknowledge its dots those are likely
gonna be effects team to digitally cover
the stand in space I just had a bunch of
moles remember as we saw in the video it
is raining the roads are slippery you do
not want three boy Edward emits day one
a production now Batman on his backs
like Tom Cruise would have done it you
of the doubt with a zero year comics
context here to read agrees coming from
the Batman's production in Glasgow
Scotland atop a hill in the city to the
east of glasgow cathedral is the
Victorian era necropolis cemetery that's
what this is cool me number of reasons
he's kind of a gloomy Gus visiting the
graves of Thomas and Martha Wayne would
probably be a bit ill-advised while
you're also taking the trouble to
disguise yourself as a Batman
mores are that said this movies working
title is vengeance and as we explored in
the last episode of rogue theory may be
very interesting to see a Batman
motivated by revenge for the murder of
Dick Grayson or Jason Todd yeah I know
we're gonna say this will be a younger
Bruce Wayne and classically bad there
better be a night way better not really
dead is exploring a version of Batman
and which begins this vigilante journey
as part of a partnership but then loses
that partner in the first year with the
reason people are pushing this is there
a been some casting rumors seeking
circus skills with some chatter that
Timothy shall oh man it could be a good
fit in some kind of quiet in our future
Gotham orphanage orphanage you know how
people put up signs for orphanages it's
all over the place
hey yeah look we get you orphan today
parents died it don't cry you are on
your way to work folks and Batman mask
and orphanage and the movie equals a
rotten figure in the movie but while
we're considering rumor and speculation
another orphan night is that we could be
seen to bat suits in this film so if you
are not a fan of the suit in these set
photos and videos we could just be
looking at an early prototype that gets
replaced or destroyed early on in the
film or that's just spin the case and
that's just what he needs to wear we're
looking at writing a backup version of
the suit with patty and specifically
just for the stunt performer in the one
patent suits up in for close-ups will be
trimmed down for a better silhouette
ultimately what it's just me most about
these images is the fact that Batman is
joined by this other character she's got
a helmet on and if likely another stunt
actor but one well-known dark cloud
Gotham woman
- but you got a movie that means
relationship with Catwoman has often
been somewhat altruistic whoa a film
what like that suit penis really had a
cannon later our buddy Jeff pitched a
pretty great theory about that many
Catwoman's dark love affair in this film
that I just really enjoyed be sure to
check that out now when these photos and
videos draft we were all over them in
new rock stars official discord server
alternate theories for Batman's follow
them on disk or people that she weighs
just by I'm all in it are discord is
really the place where the unfiltered
conversation is going on between our
staff our inner circle of supporters you
can join our discord today by becoming a
patron of new rock stars at patreon.com
slash new rock stars 501 patrons the
parents are dead now their Hall was so
what defines a blight but you need
goggles on you're savvy Batman where's
the bridge sponsorship I know something
there's love here a hold on hold on I
got out Ridge wallet and make these
great metal plated wallets you know
they're no secure you can't scan through
them to steal your info they also save a
lot of space very cool very cool
I got a theory new rock stars that you
guys did not present here maybe instead
of an early prototype bat suit
there are two Batman's in this movie how
mind-boggling would that be you should
have just thrown it out there multiverse
obviously that's not the case but your
new rock stars you're supposed to make
the craziest predictions ever and that
would have been fine coming from you
guys from us we just sound like a bunch
of idiots but from you guys who would
have been like maybe they have a point
you guys miss out on an opportunity you
have credibility it's your job to wield
it you should have done it this is the
most bit heavy new rock stars video I
think I've seen this because it didn't
have a rich sponsorship at this time
around don't fill that gap the bat-cycle
does look pretty cool looks neat you
know we haven't really seen it in action
just yet in terms of how we'll play out
in a full sequence I mean it would be
really difficult to top what they did
especially in the Dark Knight I remember
the first thing watch The Dark Knight
the bat-cycle pops out of the Batmobile
everyone applauded in the theater and
just that whole sequence is so grand
after so many years I think it's fair to
try to talk a bat-cycle sequence I mean
if you're gonna bring it back it's one
of his iconic vehicles and yeah it's
been so much time since the Dark Knight
its you gotta give it your all you gotta
try and throw that stunt flare in there
I'm not a fan of the bat symbolism on
the I don't I don't know what a
motorcycle is actual bat ears on the
front part ya know the names of sections
of bikes alright yeah with that idea
about the handlebars that just does not
seem smart to me that's you know really
dangerous and he was aesthetically
putting this together like what's he
telling the guy whoever put it together
I want it to look like a bat symbol
because I'm Batman because I'm bad that
just looks like cuz I'm Batman kind of
thing you say get it when I roll up with
my bat suit on I need it to be even more
on can't just be a regular motorcycle
this needs to look like a Batman
motorcycle yeah get it done Alfred
Catwoman's on a regular motorcycle right
next to it yeah look like cat ears yeah
on her motorcycle but the theory of the
Catwoman and batman working together for
a good portion of this film that just
makes a lot of sense it's Batman and
Catwoman there they're always either at
odds or working together or have sexual
tension it's one of the three that you
usually get with those two I like the
idea of them working together early on
the thing of like early Batman and that
this might be a prototype suit or maybe
it's just what he decides to put on when
he's gonna ride his motorcycle I gotta
change
I need my Sunday bad I need my bike
Batsuit he's got one for every occasion
like that like later on he's aerobat
when he actually starts using whatever
those things on his ribs are on his
gauntlets it's because like when we're
talking so much about early stage Batman
early prototypes and I brought this up
and the reaction we did for the Batman
first look for new rock stars a lot of
the talk has been about how this Robert
Pattinson version is gonna be a younger
bad
and maybe early days Batman but we got
all these like Batman villains already
in existence here supposedly Riddler
penguin Catwoman you know these
characters around so it can't be too
early in the Batman stages right unless
unless there's also an origin tale of
penguin and Riddler but from the way
that news reports have been getting
pitched our waves it sounded like they
have existed for a while at least yeah
and it sounds like Arkham Asylum is
going to play some kind of role and
maybe even a prominent setting of the
movie and if you're gonna be in there I
don't have to imagine that you have to
have some aspect of the rogue's gallery
already in existence already at play in
here I love the idea I didn't even think
about that of the court of owls playing
a part in this Batman movie or maybe
having them be some type of overarching
underground villain amongst it all
because League of Shadows that they're
kind of like you know assassin's Warrior
temple people and there's some
iterations even in the Gotham show
actually work the League of Shadows and
the court of al-azhar are connected to
one another in some way there are a lot
more unlike the political Eyes Wide Shut
kind of category yeah yeah you know and
I think they'd be a cool menacing secret
society that has been controlling Gotham
which is what the court vowels is but I
think to have that play a factor into
this new Batman franchise would be
pretty cool actually it's something we
haven't gotten yet I feel like for the
political climate we live in today it
could be somewhat relevant yeah actually
that would be I think that's a great
point like I don't know a heap ton about
the court about potentially crash into
the other elements of the rogues gallery
that you have because it seems like this
movie is gonna stand on its own to a
degree it doesn't seem like it needs to
be weighed down by connecting to all the
other DC things and I find it
interesting especially now that we're
diverting even further from the original
ensemble DC set up so yeah I feel like
there's a lot of potential and I think
it would be awesome to explore some
things like that because they have
announced some very well-known
characters in connection or there are
speculations of very well-known
characters it would be cool to get
something that's a little less off the
mainstream beaten path Plus that Talon
character I mean he really at least in
those comic panels reminded me of night
owl from Watchmen
but you know to get a similar Batman s
character or even just a hinted that
character
be a cool addition as well I think I
think also to in the type of lighting
though when they were showing down the
bat emblem there's so much talk about
the bat emblem is it a de tractable
Batarang are they two guns are they a
gun that's been sliced in half after
looking at this image it's the first
time I'm like oh I'm actually pretty
sold on the fact that it's a gun was
what in half this was the first time
I've ever seen that image we're looking
at a close-up on the red lighting noir
thing that we got of the camera test
footage I wasn't sold on it but looking
at it here it really does look like that
no yeah like looking at the details it
almost look like literally somebody saw
it a gun in half and I'm like pounded it
down and sharpened the edges and yeah
made them some kind of weird gun hand
you know which is like pretty twisted in
its own right just as a personal way to
hack somebody up like the rage that that
symbol carries yeah and I think if
they've worked to tease a Robin to come
I don't want there to be much emphasis
on it I would like it if it's like a
slight background nugget not even like a
obvious Easter egg of sorts like you
really gotta read into it to be able to
be like oh they at least planted a seed
of sorts where we could get a Robin in
the next movie we don't even know the
details of the story but it's like
there's so much going on in this yeah
introduced a brand new Robin it just
seems like a lot to do in one film well
and then you know especially right now
it seems like DC is thriving in these
one-off kind of capacity and so I think
it would be you know Batman seems like a
pretty safe bet even if the bets are
always safe anymore and I think that
building up to a new Robin would be a
cool thing rather than yeah just making
it another aspect that you crammed in
this movie especially because it's been
a long two like we had Chris O'Donnell
and then we had Joseph gordon-levitt
which wasn't like a full-on Robin and so
to actually build up to in the next
movie you know in the Batman to maybe
there is a young character who he does
take on as his apprentice could be a
cool thing to actually finally see in a
live-action sphere to see I hope they
don't go out of their way to shoehorn or
Robin in because especially if his young
Batman seems like that would happen a
bit later on that whole theory that it's
an like the way how they set up Ben
Affleck's Batman Heather
dead robbing beforehand presumably Jason
Todd I don't want that in here
especially when you keep saving it's
early Batman
no it's gonna first Robin it's got a
dick racing in here come on everybody
loves Dick Grayson Jesse discuss a
Grayson really fast after that first
thing because YouTube will totally miss
Reed then all right guys well what are
your theories on this footage it's gonna
be like this for the next year and a
half
subscribe to new rockstars if you
haven't done so already subscribe to the
rail rejects clear that Erna fication
Bell fall new rock stars on discord we
don't have one alright videos done
you